- [Narrator] How much would
$300,000 change your life?
- I would personally go to the dentist.
- [Narrator] How far would you go
for a chance to win it all?
- This elimination, you have a new option.
- I gotta make a move.
- I don't know how the game
is gonna shift on this.
- Under.
(crosstalk)
(beep)
- They will share a pool
of money to survive.
- What (beep) is this?
- And whatever they don't spend,
- I gotta win.
- They take home.
- This is Money Game.
(upbeat music)
(suspenseful music)
- This is it.
- Elimination round one.
- This is not fun,
but this is the game
it's in the title (beep).
(suspenseful music)
- I intend to eliminate Rek tonight.
It's mostly so that I can
get any night of sleep,
but he doesn't have any set bills to pay.
He just wants the money to get more money.
- I really don't want to get eliminated.
Yesterday night I was a little
bit more sure of myself,
but now, you know, it could be me.
The biggest competition for me
right now is participant four
VG is a big stumbling block in my way,
because she hates that I snore.
- As far as eliminating someone.
There's only one thing that like,
kind of tipped me off a little bit
when I heard Rek mention that (indistinct)
That's the only thing that
kind of was like, ah, okay.
- I wouldn't be mad to see V gone tonight.
I think the game is still
gonna be strong without her.
And I also feel that
she's going to continue
to do great things.
- I'm nervous.
I'm like, should I start
packing up my stuff?
- Oh God.
(computer beeping)
(bell dings)
- Oh my God.
(beep)
(suspenseful music)
- I'm disappointed and
if I'm being honest,
I'm a little surprised I did
my best to get along with the
everyone and be useful to the group.
I'm glad that I suggested the Mrees.
It means whoever does wind up
walking away with the money.
Hopefully, you know, we
have enough stuff that,
the prize pool won't dip too low.
Maybe they think, you
know that I'm an actress.
I'll, wind up making big money one day,
which is hopefully still the plan.
(suspenseful music)
- I feel pretty (beep) up right now.
I like her so much.
- Me snoring, I know it's a problem,
but at the same time,
doesn't really bother anybody else.
So I'd like her to go home.
I get so much needed to sleep.
(suspenseful music)
- Hi.
- Oh, I feel like this is
the most like out of bed.
I've felt.
- Really, I actually I'm good today, so.
- Isn't that great.
- When Victoria left, she
slid a note under the wall.
It seemed like she was in my corner.
It seemed like she could
have been a strong ally.
I felt like maybe had made a mistake.
- I felt really bad.
- It's not a fun feeling.
I wrote like a course last night.
- That's cool.
- Yeah.
- I know.
I don't like the silent
treatment at the end.
It just feels like-
- Yeah that's what I saw footsteps too.
I was looking at the crack of my door.
- Yeah.
- Yeah that's so weird,
- Chance to let her go.
- No, he's writing lyrics too.
Of course he wrote.
- So funny.
- You wrote this?
- Yeah.
- I felt like last
night was my first night
where it was just like
really uncomfortable.
- I was like, okay, I'm safe.
But also like, you know,
how long will I be?
- Yeah.
- Asia and I discussed voting in private
and we were mentioning two being wreck.
Even though we all talked
in Alliance together,
it made sense to vote him out next.
That's going to be hard having
a three first vote against
possibly like Chantel or Sam or Chance
when it might not go our
way might end in a tie.
It would just be easier
to go with the majority.
- Things are going, as
I assume, they would go,
depending on how eliminations go tonight.
I'd want them to think
I'm being duplicitous.
But if it's something
that furthers my game,
then it doesn't matter.
- With Kira.
I worry that she is a little
too quiet and hasn't made any
solid foundational
connections with anyone.
Like we all know who she is.
We all enjoy our company.
She's very endearing.
And even though I see myself
in her because no one is
attached to her that
she's become an target.
- Oh, this is my hair.
- It looks fine.
Yeah.
- Oh, look it.
- Oh, God.
Okay, here we go.
- The numbers coming up.
- Oh my God, did we really
only spend the 2000?
- Wow guys.
- What was it at yesterday?
- 268.
- Wow, good job.
- Wow.
- Yeah, we have a little
concern that maybe
Mrees won't show up today.
(crosstalk)
- Person who ordered it isn't here.
- But which is kind of leading
to the idea that possibly we
may have to reorder.
- It's only-
(crosstalk)
- I think my strategy at the end
of this game is to leave with
a lot of friends and I don't
know what that will get at me
money wise, but-
- What's the first thing that
you would do with the money?
- I would personally go to the dentist
because I haven't been in
like three years, yeah.
Because I don't have dental insurance.
Dentist, expensive and I'm too
poor to take care of myself.
So.
- Yeah.
- The money you would do so much for
just my personal health.
I haven't been to the
dentist in three years
and I need to get my teeth checked out.
(laughing)
(crosstalk)
(singing)
♪ Let's get it, let's get, let's get it. ♪
(laughing)
- I don't think Chantel has any
malicious intent towards me,
but I still have to win her over.
Especially with these
overnights passing notes,
because I get a feel that she
does have a slight distrust.
- Are you in there?
- What?
- Is your door open?
- Close now?
- Chantel's game is playing
a similar game to me
where she wants to be
in every conversation
and she wants to be around that way.
She's included and no one
can name drop her when we're
talking about votes.
- So basically I was gonna tell you that
I had a feeling about one.
- What?
- That's like an easy one.
You know, I'm saying other
person I have in mind,
there was like, I wrote it down.
Let me just let you read it.
- Oh, we gotta go.
- Okay, you can go.
- This whole time I've been
sitting here strategizing
and trying to figure out
like the strengths and
weaknesses and opportunities and
threats that might be presented.
So I am trying to figure out,
when is the shoe going to drop?
Where's Rex?
- Should we check him?
It's almost been like 30 minutes.
(snoring)
- He's like cut out he
probably fell back asleep.
He promised it.
- Rex
You good?
- Yeah.
Okay, he's like, I was in there.
He's like, Jen, are you okay?
- Wait, what did you say?
- What time did the alarm go off.
- You mean a little while.
- Like 15 minutes ago?
- Oh, you good, man.
(crosstalk)
How long got to teach?
Yeah.
Go in there like hi that's
all in that team buddy.
- Good morning.
- You right?
(crosstalk)
- With Rek I've noticed that
doesn't feel like he's really
connecting with everyone.
And I feel like that's gonna
affect his position in the game.
- Man.
- How you feeling man?
- I was for so long, like I slept,
I know y'all heard me slept.
- You know Rek hasn't had
the closest connections
with everybody.
So he'll be a little easier
for others to let go.
- Rek, cause we spend
12 hours with each other
in kumbaya sessions, yeah.
And then we go into our room
and then it's like, oh yeah,
it's about me.
- Right.
- Everything has to shift
again, it's like, okay.
How do I make sure that I'm here tomorrow?
- Yeah.
- Well, no, I'm not.
This is not about Iffy at all.
- Currently I have alliances
with Sam and chance right now,
Sam and I are really close, really tight.
- I don't know how the
game is gonna shift on us
and twist and stuff, but I just you know,
I know, especially with
us, you know, honestly,
I was in there and I was like,
I feel like maybe he might
look at me as someone he wanted
get rid off.
There's evidence situations
with other black people
and it's like.
- It's like, oh, they're gonna be honest.
- Because we are the outlier.
And we hang out with people
who don't look like us.
It's always like, he don't
love us certain conversations.
I was like, oh, I hope he
doesn't think, you know,
we're not listening him
or we feel like, you know,
he can't be himself.
- No, I feel so hard.
- Yeah.
- I feel in general, I'm really
grateful in general or like?
- You and Sam like have
made this like work for me.
Because Sam is aligned with Chan,
I'm by default aligned with Chan.
Honestly, Chan wouldn't
have been my first choice
for the Alliance, but because
I'm trusting Sam's decision,
I'm 100% on board.
- And when you're constantly
the alt black person.
- [Man] Right, right.
- You don't always wanna put
yourself out there too much.
'Cause then was just like,
you're anti-black, you're not-
- [Man] Right, right.
- It's always like (sobbing)-
- Yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
Let's hold on together
as long as we can, okay.
- I feel like this is a
really strong Alliance.
- As far as I'm concerned
you two and my book are safe,
'cause like we can communicate
in Korean and just crazy.
You know what I mean?
And you know (beep) you have.
Yeah definitely I think,
I think we're on the same page for sure.
- Man, just square forward.
Just be careful man.
Try to be like a little bit
more engaged with the others.
'Cause you don't, you don't know.
I don't know, yeah.
But it's just observation wise.
You know what I'm saying?
Like right should try to be more open
with the rest of the group.
Yeah, more hunky.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I used a Korean word
humate that means together and I
told him like, you have to
be more together with us.
Otherwise you're gonna
fall by the wayside.
Facts.
'Cause you're not a similar, I'm like
oh he stays in his room too.
Before he comes out.
- I think yesterday I couldn't
shake the feeling that people
were also looking at me as
a target also just from the
relationships that I seen
people were building,
they seemed a little bit
stronger than my bonds with them.
- After this elimination is
they're gonna drop like a double
or something crazy. Like last few days.
- Like it could be like where one person
gets to dictate the vote.
- Yeah.
- I think my place is better
now than what it was yesterday.
I was kinda worried this
morning, like, okay.
I need to figure out a way to try
and be one with the group again.
- All right, Joe.
Here it is my plan to make time fly.
- Okay.
- Okay let's do it you know,
usually what makes time
five for me is when I'm know
something's coming up.
So I was thinking, what
if we have a schedule?
- Oh, respect,
- Wake up we figure out.
you know how much we have lost,
and you know we go over
like our wants and needs.
And after that,
we maybe we do like a
little learning session.
(crosstalk)
- Because he has such a calm demeanor
and is able to kinda
of process information
a little bit more slower
than everyone else
and really feel everything.
He'll consider us as a group,
as opposed to saying this
is what we should do.
- Yeah I'm gonna lead you.
Do you guys wanna learn how to rap?
- Yeah sure let's do it.
- He's able to become a
good impromptu leader,
in the way that we didn't
have with Victoria.
He stepped up and I'm really impressed.
- I'll go first.
Miscellaneous room me in the bucket.
Poop is the hand.
I am the puppet.
Wet wipes saw me I am baby's ass.
Everett of a bowel
syndrome I am grown man.
(laughing)
Miscellaneous room forever alone, man.
- That was good, man.
- I am crying in the floor
- That's the rapper right there.
- Who wants to go next.
- Booty water so fricking bomb.
Okay, then now we all say yes.
So that's how it's gonna start.
I instantly equated it
to my girlfriend, okay.
'Cause it was just like booty,
it was just like booty water.
Like don't worry about it.
We've been talking a lot about
racism and it is a topic of,
interest for me because
my girlfriend is black.
It's not an experience
I get to live through,
but it's an experience that
I get to see people that I
really know and love going through that.
So it's easy for me to
connect through bridging these
friends with people at home.
Booty water, so freaking bomb.
Yes.
And my baby got the skin of
Michelle Obama and the booty so
big, like the soccer moms
and the taste good like I'm at Benny hons.
- Bag on my ass, I got a bag on my ass.
If you don't wanna
(indistinct) close your nose
when I pass at the end
of my rope, you say,
can you take my bag?
I say, nope.
Keep it in my room cause we vote
and that's murder she wrote.
- So I have a concern.
If two goes tonight,
how are you gonna get.
- Same concern.
- What do you think?
- I was thinking somebody other than two
because in two can, like,
he's almost a bigger target
and we can hold onto him for a
bit.
- Seven.
- I agree.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
You don't need to talk
about it again yeah.
- All right.
If they put us in pairs,
you and I can't pair up.
- Thank you, last night
I was thinking it'd be really
interesting if there was like
a final two.
- My God.
That would be wild, yeah.
That would be wild.
My eyes are watering a lot and
I don't know if it's because
I was crying so much yesterday.
- I don't know.
- I do not think that Rek
realizes he's a shield,
which really guts me because
I feel that re is really like
attaching himself to me.
But I have this final two a chance.
And if we're forced to vote
each other out all the way down
to final two, there has to
be some sort of deception.
How do you, feel about seven?
- I know Shannon and Chance
are both voting seven.
The only one I haven't talked to is AJ.
cause they're like a duo.
- Don't even tell that.
Cause I know a couple people
were already saying it and I
was like, I'm gonna go to Rek
- Sure.
- Obviously I'll let you know
more towards us the day goes.
Yeah.
Okay.
- Did we get 'em.
- Guys?
But doesn't seem that lit dude.
- Before her elimination
Victoria suggested that we would
purchase MREs.
Unfortunately she was eliminated.
So without her here, we
couldn't get the MREs.
We had to make a whole
nother purchase for MREs.
We need to boil water.
- We have to boil water.
- Yeah, I feel like they
did that on purpose.
Yeah, they used to have like the MREs.
Used to be like blocks.
Like you just like open you just eat it.
- All what we wanted,
whatever this shit.
- That's why.
- You should have known.
- Victoria's strange, man.
She got us.
- Normally at home I eat
about five to six meals a day.
So given the amount of
food we intake here,
I feel like my body's in
jitters the entire game.
- Hot plates 5,000 pot is 2000.
I think we should do hot plate pot
'cause it's way more uses.
- Let's sit on it for a
second and all think together.
Like, let the stress go a bit.
- Hot pot and top plate and--
(girl exclaims)
- Am sorry,
(girl laughs)
there will be an elimination in two hours.
- Oh my God.
- For this elimination,
you have a new option.
Okay.
- Today you can buy one additional vote
for 5% of the reigning pot.
To purchase and vote write
one extra mark on your ballot.
You can vote twice for the same person.
- Holy shit.
- Your votes will remain anonymous.
- Oh my God.
This stuff, wow.
Okay.
- Holy shit.
- Wow (laughs).
- That's a game changer.
- It was expected 'cause I jokingly said,
what if elimination could be paid for?
- I'm never stressed ever.
And right now this last 10
minutes have done me so in.
Holy shit.
- Y'all making my bro worry.
- Okay, so I wanted to talk to y'all.
I have been kinda collecting my thoughts
for the past few days.
I just, right now my financial
situation is very stable.
And one thing that I decided was like,
I don't have an immediacy for
this, like for this price.
So I'm voting for myself tonight,
and feel free to do the same.
- Feel a little cry.
- It's okay, it's okay.
Just the fact that I am, you know,
I'm sleeping next to Kira who,
like the first thing
she wanted to do is get,
go to the dentist and
that like shattered my world a little bit.
Just someone needing the basic needs
and hearing about chances,
stories about being homeless
and then even hearing
about Sam's stories about,
you know, his dog and stuff.
And I think realizing
that this is not a game
and that me winning would
not be just winning a prize,
it would be potentially taking
something away from someone
that did not sit right with me.
- I don't feel happy.
- No I mean, I said that, I
mean it when I say it too,
if you change your mind, please.
- No, I appreciate.
- You know what's gonna happen,
he's gonna be closing the door tonight,
looking at me and going sucker.
(people laughing)
If anyone has like an arch nemesis in this
that they want to get rid of,
this would be the perfect time to do it.
You could put your finger on the scale.
(suspenseful beat)
(alarm ringing)
- With the ending elimination,
I'll be voting for myself.
And I hope everyone votes for me
'cause I'd love to be
useful on the way out.
Yep.
- I will respect my Prince's
wishes and vote number five.
- I knew this was coming
because while we were
passing notes last night,
he mentioned this to me.
I respect your decision,
but I wish you didn't, you
know, I wish you didn't go.
- I just wanna say thank
you for being really cool,
being a really good friend.
- It's upsetting, but
you made it easy for us.
You wanna go home?
We'll let you go home.
(soft music)
(screen beeping)
(suspenseful music)
- I feel physically and mentally prepared
to handle the game, I think.
But I think I started to wonder I'm like,
am I doing this for the right reasons?
I shouldn't be competing for
something that I don't need.
(suspenseful beat)
- When AJ came to us and told
us that he wanted to go home,
it's super unexpected just
because AJ seemed to fit,
just really took me by surprise.
- I feel like I was in the same position
as like was just like, you know, like,
am I capable of going all 10 days?
Like, am I gonna get voted
out before the 10 day's up?
Do I know I'm gonna be voted
- Right yes.
Do I feel a shift in the wind?
- Yeah.
- I just feel I don't know.
I was like having thoughts last night.
it's like my life is over,
Like whether I'm here or not.
- Oh no, no ,no, no.
- Like I was thinking
that like-
- Life so often feels impossible.
- It Feels so(beep) hard.
- Yeah.
- You really showed your shit today, man.
Respect.
(beep)
- Yeah, yeah, that was cool.
- Yeah I can be real with you.
That's why I told you earlier today,
like I guess you know,
hum care, young money
that kind of like forever
together for every type of shit.
I got you man.
(suspenseful music)
(siren ringing)
- Yeah,
- let's get it.
(siren ringing)
- We just move today's plan
to the next elimination.
She actually wants to go home so--
- Oh really?
(siren ringing)
- At this point I'm trying
to build my alliances,
but they're not completely there yet.
(siren ringing)
- After Victoria left,
I felt like the only real
targets were myself and Rec.
Just because we are kinda the
two quieter ones in the group.
Rec was kinda mysterious
and I kinda disassociated at times.
So yeah, I definitely felt like a target.
- I think everyone here
is equally deserving
and however the vote plays out.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Man.
- So now you know.
- Yeah.
Last night I spent a lot of
time looking at the numbers,
and all the cast and seeing
like how it would play out,
like who I would vote
for and all that stuff.
And I couldn't really place AJ.
It makes things easier,
but it also makes things harder now
because now I just don't know.
So today I kinda stepped it up.
(screen beeping)
- All right y'all.
- Good night, everyone.
- Good night.
(siren ringing)
- I can't wait to get my day started.
I'm ready to play.
I'm focused now.
I have a strategy now.
Next elimination might gotta make a move.
I gotta win.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] Next time on "Money Game."
- Sam and Shannon,
being able to pass those
all throughout the night
it's starting to worry me.
- I feel like there is an opportunity
for me to be voted out.
- Anybody's the most deserving is us.
You know what I'm saying?
- This is becoming super
an emotional thing.
- Here almost feels like more comfortable
than like being at home.
(beep)
- Is she playing games with all this.
- Either she's playing
games or she's convinced
and either way I'm not safe.